welcome back to rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and adventures in game wasn't just
the victorious finish to the infinity
saga it also championed some of the
supported players of the MCU that
otherwise never really got their chance
to shine
recently the film's editor revealed that
the newest Marvel hero Captain Marvel
had a much more complicated role in this
film's production than we even realized
her showdown with Dan Oates in the final
melee he said was a last-minute reshoot
the more I investigate and re-watch
endgame along with other recent MCU
films the more it becomes clear hot take
incoming Avengers in game as a film did
a better job depicting Carol Danvers as
a heroic Avenger and future team member
then her own Captain Marvel origin movie
did I'm gonna break down the reasons why
in this special update episode of inside
Marvel
[Music]
look this is nothing to get to Captain
Marvel film it was a story I really
enjoyed particularly for the ways that
connected the dots in the MCU with the
tesseract Nick Fury in the origin of the
Avengers but brie Larson as Carol
Danvers for me went through that same
awkward introductory phase that Chris
Hemsworth did in the first Thor in the
way that doors true potentials only
opened up in the team dynamic of the
first Avengers film though - in my
opinion did Captain Marvel's in Avengers
in game now the odd thing to acknowledge
was that brie Larson shot most of her
endgame scenes before production on
Captain Marvel began she has described
how her entire character development
process was backwards and super
secretive when she shot the Captain
Marvel post-credit scene she was on a
green screen set alone having no idea
what movie she was shooting for how many
people were in the scene with her just
being told to look at spots on the wall
behind the scenes footage of her
shooting end game is hilariously
oblivious to doesn't feel cool but if it
looks very Larson's words here reflect a
truth about these Marvel films more than
other films these actors are
contributing chunks to a bigger picture
that's really being painted in a whole
different room by directors editors and
VFX artists and games editor Jeff Ford
revealed recently that Captain Marvel's
arrival smashing through thanasis [ __ ]
was in the script from day one but her
fistfight with Thanos at the end was put
together in reshoots this actually could
have been shot after the Marvel Studios
team had seen what was being put
together for the Captain Marvel film
even though these Captain Marvel resuits
an in-game were assembled during a
chaotic correction period for Larson the
finished product and endgame is actually
a version of the character that really
hits the nail on the head Thanos for the
first time in this in-game final battle
terrifyingly slips his hand inside that
starlet ready to end it all rip the
universe to shreds and start over and
the last possible second Carol dives in
there
and stalls them gets in a few good
Wallops and during the headbutt honestly
my favorite part of this brawl is the
way it ends danos Yanks a Power Stone
out of the gauntlet and use it to plunge
Captain Marvel out of the movie he
learns that even includes this great
look of WoW right before it happens in
doing so this character endures a rite
of passage at every avenger must face
they gotta take a ridiculous hit well
before I continue thanks to the ridge
for sponsoring this episode the ridge
makes everyday goods to a standard you
don't see every day they streamline your
life by turning the things you carry
like you know backpacks of chargers
wallets the tools
men are living the flagship products the
ridge wallet was launched on Kickstarter
in 2013 and now sits in the front
pockets of over half a million men and
women I wouldn't saw the world from a
lopsided angle because I've had a
stuffed wallet propping me up like I'm a
puppet then I swapped it out for this
front pocket Ridge wallet where its leak
leakin Taine's all my cash in the cards
this is their aluminum wallets in the
raw color they have other colors
including some very flashy
Tiki designs it's light it's strong it
has this cool industrial chic vibe I
don't know what chic means but this is
chic the ridge is a minimal front pocket
wallet that is designed to streamline
what you carry every day 30,000
five-star reviews and it is a better way
to carry your cash in your cards there's
a lifetime warranty if you'll love it
and free returns if you don't it comes
in titanium carbon fiber aluminum and
over a dozen different styles of colors
we also got their weather proof commuter
backpack that comes with a shock
resistant laptop holder in a hidden RFID
blocking pocket get 10% off today with
free worldwide shipping and returns by
are going to ridge comm slash new rock
stars that's ridge comm slash new rock
stars and user code new rock stars find
the link in the description below see in
screenwriting there is a maxim called
saving the cat in which you show a hero
performing a small ancillary heroic task
early on in the film to convey that they
are an inherently good person that we
can get behind now in the MCU we should
call it hitting the cap you have to
physically knock the hero on their ass
so that they can prove their heroism by
getting back to their feet something
they shouldn't be able to do all day
this just might have been my Carol's art
didn't land that hard with me and her
Captain Marvel film like in that story
Carol's vulnerability comes from her
memory loss how the authority figures in
her life have manipulated and gaslighted
her absolutely an interesting struggle
but physically she's like out matches
and dominates everyone she shares the
screen with and no point does she seem
in real physical danger and if you think
about it her rise only comes because
everyone else around her gets dragged
down like we have to choose who's
powerful rather than share the power
look there is something to be said for
empowering tales that center around
normally marginalized groups finally
getting their due like what I love about
films like alien my favourite film is
that it tells this kind of story without
hitting us over the head with the gender
politics resulting in one of the most
nuanced and accurate portrayals of a
woman in the workplace getting ignored
and talked over until reality proves her
rights and she alone just
feels of the problem by doing what she
wanted to do the whole time in the movie
ends with her napping with her cat it's
perfect
Ripley struggle and alien is both
specific to her gender but also a
situation that everyone can relate to
and her power is discovered it was there
within her all along but it's activated
by circumstance
by contrast Carol Danvers power is like
accidentally spilled on her never really
earned and while I'm sure some audiences
can watch her rise and be like yes
finally something for me that reaction
comes at the expense of everyone else
not really having an empathy for her
struggle which is why I'm so grateful
for the way the character is portrayed
and endgame and it's not just because
she gets walloped into space endgame
Carol Danvers is still confident as any
badass former pilot should be but that
confidence is aimed at helping other
people and being part of a team rather
than like dunking on everyone in sight
she rescues Tony Stark she's the first
to march off in a battle and get revenge
against Thanos when they find out where
he is
she doesn't flinch when Thor summons the
hammer past her face just to test her
kind of a dick move and later she pranks
rocket by making him saving garbage ship
she compassionately checks in with Rudy
at the end of that meeting she has a
really fun exchange at the Peter Parker
and she leads the ladies on an awesome
charge and yeah as we've mentioned she
saves the others from Hellfire by
wrecking the henesys ship she takes a
headbutt from him and hilariously blasts
away like a Smash Bros ko
the Captain Marvel when Captain Marvel
is an oddly smug angry warrior who can't
remember anything and thinks the only
way to rise in power is Doody power
everyone around her the Captain Marvel
an endgame is an active team player who
bounces back from hard hits and rises to
higher heights by lifting up her
powerful friends that is an Avenger that
is a hero worthy of inspiring the name
of the Avengers initiative and that is
an Avenger I think we can all get on
board with leading the team in future
installments so what do you think might
be too hard on Captain Marvel am I gonna
get canceled for this take hope not
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on instagram and twitter at EA
vas following new rock stars on socials
and subscribed into rock stars on
youtube do join us as we go deeper and
deeper inside marvel thanks for joining
me
[Music]